[Music]
the what podcast which fans this year
not only a week away from coachella but
how many days away from bonnaroo
69. wow nice
nice to see you guys i can't believe i
get to see your faces in person the
gang's all together yeah do we do like
uh like an air hug or something what do
we do we don't like to touch i don't
like touching i don't want to touch no
touching to learning that's my theory
that's right that's right uh now why are
we here together today well i'm glad you
brought it up hey wait a second
russ
why does he have a nicer mic than us
because i'm special
wait a second
that's right this
is your chair tall or two
can be this is really good i don't like
anything about this yeah
well it's that's okay because i was
gonna brag on you because uh the reason
we're here is because you're on your way
to a new job and i wanted to point out
to all the kids out there and people
with dreams that uh you can make it in
radio doing weather and sports yeah and
traffic updates you can fail
at every level of your job and still get
ahead failing up brad that is me
uh yeah so new orleans is incredible
it's my favorite city in the world and
it's going to be the place where we end
up
in fact i mean even driving driving up
here we were still looking at houses to
buy so new orleans is going to be the
place for us but you know i got this
incredibly
amazing once in a lifetime opportunity
to basically be a brand manager of three
radio stations one of which is in new
york city and my industry there's just
not a
there's not a bigger job there's not a
bigger job in the world than doing in my
industry than doing radio in new york
city so um
when you get something like that you get
an opportunity like that it's a life and
game
career changer so i don't really
as much as it hurts to leave new orleans
because we love it so much um
not taking this would be one of the
stupidest things i've ever done about it
yeah you have to and uh i don't know
about you russ well i do know because
you've been down there but i don't you
can't see it here it's in in the other
room but i now have a map with pins of
all the places i've not visited you
that's fantastic new york yeah right i
got to put another pen well early enough
you can put chattanooga on there too
because you never came over that's right
that's right i've never been to ringgold
yeah it's it you won't be able to see
the map very it does sort of feel like
christmas every time we come here
because we always got to go to dad's
house so we always gotta yes it's like a
homecoming we gotta pet the cat we gotta
ask how the fireplace is doing you know
have you made any adjustments to the
house where's my how's my room doing
yeah it's good for us too because this
is the only time it gets clean you know
when company's coming so
thanks
boy what a job you did yeah
what a job it's usually not this neat
i see one bin of lysol and that's about
it
yeah that's just for show too how do you
not keep this thing from being one big
dust cloud you've got so much stuff in
here i mean if you could like spin the
camera around and see like the
collectibles you have how do you not
just collect nothing but dust in here
that's what's keeping it together i i
yeah it's awful it's embarrassing it's
uh no it's not embarrassing i think it's
a it's it's something to celebrate how
in my house everything is covered is it
because i have dogs
that well yeah we have cats
we have a cat
um i do clean and i
i start at one end
and when you get into the southern end
yeah they're this this room uh-huh now
we're remodeling the other side of this
downstairs so that's why
how's the house how's the remodel yeah
gotta check on the remodel what's my
room look like started 25 years ago
and uh just when we left the house
someday
yeah when you kids moved out
started yeah
it's um
it's a work in progress well i'm just
happy to see you guys anyway what's uh
what about you guys life what have you
guys been doing i mean i don't really
have a point of the show today other
than just hanging out
yeah that's i i got nothing um i went to
a show last night
stop it i did wait last what last night
i'm late
till when
10 15. oh my god he saw double digits
yeah i was good at that hello
chattanooga and door closes in fact when
i when i left i thought oh this is
perfect because it's classic
three songs gotta go yeah i saw five
man five i uh uh whiskey myers i am uh
i'm stunned by all of this first and
foremost why did you go out
uh there were some people in town that i
went to see it was actually a business
meeting more than it was a concert so
you'll go see them at night but you
won't hang out with us at night i was
going to say where was my invite yeah it
was last minute i should have invited
you i have to say i was at memorial
auditorium and it's incredible what
they've done to that place i know you
know it's chattanooga centric but
it's pretty cool yeah it's pretty cool
well i mean everything's cool to
somebody who's never seen anything
it's so big look how big yeah
i dated her once yeah um this is what
this looks like yeah so uh so you went
to see a show dad went out uh
taco house how's life with you
it's fine okay yeah
you've got a big event why would i
expect anything different uh yeah uh
this is this is bugapalooza weekend for
us big uh happy bugapalooza
big volkswagen show swap meet camp out
so that's where i'll be this weekend
well i mean if we're a week away from
coachella there's the uh the coachella
information that came out that i don't
know if anybody's really that interested
in weekend and swedish house mafia take
over for kanye who um
whether it's his decision or not he's
not doing uh coachella and uh
i the only thing that that struck me
about the coachella stuff was how
quickly they just have
superstars just ready to go you know i
and it's not a knock on bonnaroo it's
just a harder it's a harder putt there's
it's a harder way it's a harder thing to
do to get somebody to get to nashville
on a whim
um with a stage show than in
you know 30 miles from l.a
well it's
part of what i was talking about last
night
was
basically industry people and we were
talking about
coachella and festivals in general and
the changes that we've seen
since we've been doing this and in the
last 15 years as you've said many many
times coachella has a ton of money
and can do a whole lot of things
uh that some others can't but the real
conversation was just how
things have changed like a lot of
festivals it was pointed out or two days
now
and bonnaroo is added a day
or two really if you
you know if we were getting there
wednesday night now we're supposed to
get there tuesday um at the day and a
half depending on when you get there i
mean who can do that i know i mean okay
i know you can't
he's already packed
when you have a car for a house it's a
lot easier
it's just like even last year i've been
i've been
reflecting a lot on
especially the cancellation and then the
reschedule and the amount of work it was
going to take for me to do it even from
new orleans and
how in the world am i going to do that
now from new york
it's one thing to do a couple of days i
don't know how
these kids i think of i think of the ham
kids how in the world do they get a week
where they just say okay i'll be gone
from monday to wednesday
i have already planned for my year next
year
thursday to wednesday for mardi gras
i mean yeah if i do another week of
vacation for bonnaroo that's that i'm
done for the year and i'm ju
how does anyone regularly do that and
this is the first time i'm really ever
having to to talk about like basic
problems like this that yeah listener of
this podcast has dealt with for year
after year after year yeah reality
yeah you don't live an hour from the
farm anymore so it's it's it's an event
to get down there just just the trip
itself yeah i mean even for even for
barry who you know
you can work remotely yes but
can you spend eight days on that farm
work-wise or physically or both yeah um
yeah work-wise i could yeah i can do
[Music]
everything from there that i can do here
i'm actually considering driving up and
back
you know at least a couple of those days
uh which we can do
um because we're so close
but yeah the idea i was thinking about
that this last night
you know we started going on wednesdays
because of the media day and that was a
big move for us huge because i mean at
the time i was still a little iffy about
you know
not showering sure and heat that's
exactly right
that's exactly right now you've added a
whole nother day which
really think about it that's tuesday
wednesday
thursday because things don't start till
three this is how a calendar works i
don't know if you know
tuesday wednesday thursday
never seen one yeah that's three right
um
well but i'm just saying that so
when we would get there on wednesday
night it was great because
we would rush and get everything set up
and then we could relax
thursday for things to start on thursday
now you've got a camp basically with no
entertainment
other than the wednesday night thing
that rubus guys are planning or some of
that
yeah they've got a big thing wednesday
night planned yeah so now you're gonna
have to figure out
i mean a two day overnight camping two
nights would be
camping for me
you know that's a big weekend
and that's on top of the festival
so it's a pretty so where every other
festival is is going in one direction
bonnaroo's going in the other one
and maybe there's a really good um
maybe that's a bonus for bonnaroo maybe
that's something that actually makes
them unique and and the the special
experience that it is but i wonder if
you're doing the math and if you're you
know a c3 or a live nation asking the
question what does it look financially
if we just turn this into a three-day
you know two-night event um all of a
sudden maybe
maybe the conversation changes i don't
know you know they're having that
conversation oh absolutely you know they
they know by the penny what these things
are going to give them
well that's the other thing that now
they have to staff all of that you know
um
so there there's a lot to it
the reason they're doing it clearly is
the parking the
bottleneck
you know this is their solution to help
get everybody inside the festival right
right yeah add
another day and stagger the entrance
that's exactly what it is and you know
we've seen in the news just this week
there's some conversations going on with
the state and the city and the county
about well that's i want to get to that
because i because i'm not smart enough
to understand that so you're going to
have to explain all of that to me but
first
have we heard anything about coachella's
ticket sales
has coachella sold out
i haven't i have not heard have you
heard of any festival saying that
they've sold out no no yeah okay it what
it makes me start to wonder because we
had this conversation a couple of months
ago
when we uh get through
the first festival season alana kovid
what does it look like afterwards and
and who was the one that succeeded who
are the ones that failed
i really don't know
anything about the ticket sales when it
comes to any of these festivals i wonder
how well it's doing
my thought and again as part of the
conversation last night
is because we've all been basically you
know shut down for three years
um
it feels like a a reset you know
everybody wants to have a festival
there's a bunch of them out there
oh it sounds so
um
great lineups you know here and there
they are as we've talked about some of
them are figuring out their lanes
they're the boutiques
um
there's that which ones survive and
which ones are successful
which ones the crowds are choosing that
was sort of a conversation that we had
with several people last night
is you know bonnaroo was
there were only a few
and it proved that people would camp
and then we've seen the the boutique
ones for people who don't want to camp
who want something closer to home well
the the only one that i can point to
that has been
the overwhelming darling and the success
story of the year was when we were young
it was so successful on the first day
they added a second day and it was so
successful adding a second day they had
a second weekend so um you know but at
the same time that festival
is highly specific with every band that
they they put on there so uh and it was
a market that had not been tapped in a
very long time so other than that i
don't really know how anyone's doing
yeah
and it may be you know line-up
dependent but you know something tells
me that it's in my gut i just don't know
if it's the lineup or if it's about our
appetite for these things anymore and i
wonder if and i may be
pontificating way too large and
being a tad obtuse about this but
there's just something in this that
makes me feel as
though the festival world is starting to
lose its
lose its oomph yeah maybe because
there's too many of them maybe because
they're they've been nationalized and
corporatized uh and the ones that are
really small and specific and and
homemade they're the ones that are
succeeding i don't know i really don't
know yeah you were shaking your head
it's well it's hard to get excited about
a festival because we've had so many
years of cancellations and you know
false starts and postponements that you
know now you're like i don't want to get
invested in something that's just going
to end up not happening again so
until until we have several that are i
don't know i've dated before so i yeah
okay something always brings you back
isn't there so until then we have
several that are successful it's gonna
be hard to get back into the rhythm of
oh i'm excited for this and i'm gonna
plan for it and
put all my energy well i mean i know
russ's answer about this but what is the
excitement level
for bonnaroo right now on a one to ten
for barry one to ten berries how many
given
six
really okay
yeah i'm about middle of the road really
yeah i mean okay well now it's done now
i want to be excited but i just you know
yeah after after 2021 were you okay so
you're middle of the pack now but were
you middle of the pack in 2019
oh i was no i was way up at this point
69 days out oh yeah oh yeah
yeah 20 that yeah
2019 and going into 20 i was a 9 or 10 i
was there was no question no hesitation
absolutely part of it is as russ just
said the two years
there's a little bit of
loss of trust a little bit of
uncertainty
we even said last year
they made changes as they do every year
so there's a question of how it's going
to impact us personally
which is always huge we you know we've
been spoiled we know it
um
and we can uh
we can complain and [ __ ] if it we don't
get our way i mean
you know we're gonna
if we don't get what we're used to i'm
not saying that because if i said it i
would be
murdered
i would be strung up on the street no
it's the truth
but the other thing and jeff cuellar
pointed it out when we had him on the
show a couple of weeks ago we're all
getting older
you know our expectations of comfort
levels
and all of that have changed well i mean
i think this is highly personal but the
general the general public
and the overall age demographic of these
festivals they're not getting older
they're saying exactly the same or
getting younger so i mean
that's a that's a in the bubble sort of
uh argument i don't i think you and i
are getting older so our excitement
level is changing
but that demographic is big enough to
matter
i mean they're not really worried about
just this three things yeah i know i
don't i don't i just i don't think i
agree with that
this demographic may
be a big one but the demographic under
us is just as big
and they've yeah but are they going are
they gonna go for
seven or six days
has it become the rite of pa is it still
the rite of passage that it was even
three or four years ago
is a question or has it been replaced
with other festivals that have
you know the lineup that the
that age group whatever that age group
wants
or you know
edm specific the boutique things you
know there are so many festivals
that people can pick and choose
and
the reality is bonnaroo is a camping
festival that's now
six days five at minimum
and as you said a minute ago
not everybody can do that i guess i
guess the point you're right but
you're back to the jeff cuellar thing if
you
sidebar if you haven't listened to the
chat that we had with jeff cuellar a
couple of weeks ago please go back and
listen to that because it's so well done
for him not i hadn't done no has nothing
with us but he's just such an incredibly
great and gifted communicator and he
gets things so clearly to you and
especially the back half of that
conversation where he talks a lot about
bonnaroo and festivals in general was
really really important
and it makes me it informs my uh initial
opinion which could change but i wonder
if because of
what we've gone through the last two
years maybe we're looking for something
a little different and maybe this is
uh become
festival life maybe the festivals have
become a vcr
it's become a little bit of a relic of
the past and we're all trying to find
something
a little bit more different and if we
are looking for
the
demographic below you and i
what am i talking about below me and
russ uh then the still breathing
is that what you mean
i like to call them the uh marriage
they're they're basically all the kids
getting married right now yeah you know
you know like group of that group of
years where's like dramatically 5 34
where it's like ever it's festive it's
wedding season every year you've got
from 25 to 34 it's like constant
weddings yep
that group
i wonder if that group
desires something so much more different
than this relic of festival
life
it's a good question i mean you're right
like my my son probably
has gone to 35 weddings since he
graduated college
easily some he's in some he's not some
are out of town it it's not cheap
i mean
and now he's having children so you know
you're losing that but there's another
wave coming up
i'll go back to what i said earlier this
year feels like a reset kind of year
to your point so you think it's just a
blip he thinks it's just i think well
i think they're gonna have to figure
something out yeah and i think part of
it is there's this desire by everybody
to get out
you know and have fun again
and that's part of why we're seeing all
these festivals and all these great
lineups the bands want to get out
um how many of them
survive you know we're gonna we'll see i
don't know i
i don't want to predict and i'm not
saying bonnaroo is in in trouble or
anything like that we still i still love
it
you know i know there are people who are
planning just like they always do
uh robust
folks like we heard from kevin or i did
from
uh from camper room camp rederoo the
beer exchange is planned they've got
huge plans i mean it's still very much
yeah there's a big portion they're just
ready to fall right back into it and get
back into the right normal swing of it
it's just are the are there gonna be as
many people also when they open up those
bathrooms why didn't they throw a rave
on top of the bathroom
you know put a dj on top of the bathroom
when they first opened them as like a
celebratory thing i've never
figured out yeah you're thinking out of
the box yeah
um have we heard anything about those
plaza experiences yet you have to please
understand
i hate to be a host of a podcast about
uh festivals and not know anything about
what's going on the festival please
understand my life has been a complete
whirlwind over the last few months so i
know nothing that's been going on so
everything that you tell me is going to
be brand new to me you've been a little
distracted
how many messages have gone by in our
text thread that i just have not seen
yeah yeah traffic and weather that'll
keep you hey it keeps you employed for a
long time keeps you busy
they have they
they released a whole lot of late night
stuff for the plazas oh really
i don't recognize any name okay i don't
come to you for my late night
recommendations barry
late night for barry is four o'clock
if there was a golden buffet a golden
corral buffet maybe i'd come to you from
my lineup
uh
examination we have sweet potatoes and
we have scallop potatoes get there early
it's cheaper
my headliner tonight's a dehumidifier
gotta get that early bird
i mean you tell me how many of those
names you recognize not a single one i
would well okay um
airs earth air tour you're making me
read this because you can't see it i
know that's not true
that's not true at all you look at these
and tell me i do recognize one i see dj
mill turnpike troubadour that's obama's
dj
wait a second i've there's a lot of
obama dj's
well look how many though that's the
other thing i mean you could i mean
that's a festival lineup in itself you
could almost never leave i know we were
looking at a pic but i i need you to
tell me who it is
does russ need to read it no i can't
read it but seriously you don't need to
tell me if you can tell me you can be
vulnerable if you can't well i mean
there's it's a it's
every night
the lineup is as big as the main lineup
i mean do you read them all brett
douglas flatland calvary i mean
tell me when you hear a name you
recognize
i'm gonna be here for a while [ __ ]
okay so let me ask you this so this is
this is the lineup that they're just
doing for this is not like the plaza
stuff where you would see a haley from
paramore this is plaza's this is the
plaza schedules oh
uh-huh that's not even late night that
and then they released the who stage
stuff too
uh
so is anybody i know there brie kennedy
did which was she wouldn't
one of our uh
no no
sawyer
you're just saying words i am i'm just
tell me when you recognize the name
wax owls
you're just making up
coakley this is the this is the bonnaroo
what is that game that we played where i
made up
james no that's no faker festival
i think i see a few names on there i
probably dated yeah
parrotfish that's not a real band name
that's right that's not real
it's right there
um
and i'm not i don't mean to make light
of these guys good for them they're
getting opportunity to play um my point
if anything is
like you just said well you could never
go into center room but i thought that
the plaza had always there was a name or
two that you could always like point as
like oh
awful band from nashville
that uh
you're gonna have to narrow it down yeah
that it's a two person the doses and
mimosas people those kids they were on
there one year the next year is haley
from parramore
there's always a name out there like the
cagey elephant did a pop-up private show
or not private show but a pop-up
surprise show out there they did and
haley was in there because she curated
one of the plazas so they haven't until
we don't have a specially curated plaza
from an artist i don't think so okay
well they haven't announced all those i
mean they're
they list
late night sets dance parties parades i
don't know if they're gonna bring back
the parades and secret shows okay so
so there's still more to come yeah okay
well then that makes me feel a bit
better yeah and i apologize if you
already have heard all of this i'm sorry
but i don't know anything that's going
on so you're i'm learning this all at
the first and if they do have like a
haley williams or somebody like that uh
you know in their back pocket they're
not going to announce it in the
forefront they're going well
yeah i mean it depends on ticket sales
yeah that's probably what they're
looking at they might if ticket sales
are slow uh let's try and find somebody
pretty quick uh jack johnson all of a
sudden is playing the uh
the seventh quarter what is it called
what are the pods called what what is
your pod called out there plazas they're
called plazas oh they're plaza i was in
pod two this is your first time going
yeah yeah yeah it's your first year i'm
excited for you this will be brand new
for you i'm really i have lost a lot of
bandwidth i'll be honest with you
i'm so excited for you thanks buddy i
appreciate it's my first day um so the
uh the the the plaza schedules out the
the late night shows are out there was
another thing that you just oh the how
about the the late night schedule
in actual
what stage which stage the other stage
is that out
no
they haven't announced that bands are
gonna be playing late at night we
haven't seen that yet have we i don't
think so no i think i know moon river
comes out next tuesday that's different
festival i know it is but same people is
what i'm saying um
i know they've told me when that
schedule comes out but i don't remember
bonnaroo's i haven't seen it
i have not yeah okay
all right so we don't know
the only thing that i oh god isn't it
huh
well that's what no that's when they
actually put the schedule that's what
i'm saying but i thought they would have
announced at least who's playing late
night
like
years
like give me the give me that give me
the stamina for a second like for
instance um we know for a fact that a
lillinium is going to be
an aft like yes at one o'clock in the
morning
which stage act right we know that for
fact that's it okay so that's what i was
talking about yeah that's exactly what
i'm looking for so on on friday king
gizzard and lizards is you know probably
a wit or this
tent right goose is probably a that tent
denzel curry
you know you're over there on a tent a
lineum you think they put them on
the other or you think they put them
late night at which
uh
see that's that's what i'm gonna that's
what that's the that's the conversation
right so flume
do they put fl mark ribella or however
the how you say his last name him on the
witch would be incredible but it's going
to be a tent show for sure right
um pigeons playing ping pong that's a
that's a tent show no sunday night huh i
guess we're done after uh yeah what's
your name all right
interesting
yeah see this is the other thing
thursday i thought there would be a
little bit more
late night stuff than that there's got
to be more to be announced here right
there's more than five late night shows
on friday am i wrong to assume that
sounds about right really
but again we don't know what all is
going on in the plazas oh yeah good
point you know
okay so
i
i was thinking
you know we always make our schedules
when it comes out we all that we all
spend all these days leading up to it
it's so many choices now i can't even
imagine trying to
say i'm going to do this well do we want
to put out do we want to put out our
mock schedule but do we all want to take
a uh yeah well we got to get started we
got to get stoned to do it just so you
know we can i love getting stoned make
make fun of him because oh see how
interesting it is oh brian brian i
thought you just wanted us just
generally to get stoned no laminating mr
laminate we got to get him to do his
laminated schedule so that's what we'll
do we'll we'll do a fill in the blank
we'll make our own schedule and see who
gets closest yeah so we can then go
through it and you can point out and say
brian he's not even on the schedule yeah
he's he's dead now yeah it's just
nothing but
pink floyd cover band
you know pearl jam sure yeah in my car
i sit in my car
sing along to the shins
get high and sleep this whole time is
blocked out here's me and my car
listening to people jam
me with some
blue haired girl yeah sure i get it uh
so let's do that and by the way speaking
of do it
we got the winner right you guys talked
to the winner yes yeah dave david grimes
oh yeah david grimes what about what
about grimy how's he
he's doing great uh that was it was who
was the he was the one where you looked
very svelte yeah he knew he looked great
yeah he nailed it yeah yeah
he really knew his audience there was no
spot to us
yeah the only thing he could have done
better was send cash was that the
by the way we're not opposed to being
bribed entirely for whatever you need um
by the so was that the one where in the
background there was a there was a
picture of the stage and on the side it
said a baby
no no oh i like that one was close i
like that one i thought they were all
great they they're honestly every single
one was amazing
and uh they all got uh gift packages
this week and the the mail actually it
took only about three days i've already
seen pictures of
what did everybody get oh yeah send us
pictures if you're wearing everybody got
a a shirt lovely t-shirt a sticker
a sticker
okay good yeah do we have more like gear
that we're gonna i mean you know you
should do i have an idea
if you write us
um
and
send us something send us anything you
want
barry will send you something from this
room
and you can start clearing out some [ __ ]
man
wow there's a lot of good stuff in here
there's a signed elvis poster over there
you could be winning
yeah you just endeared yourself to my
wife
yeah like i needed to yeah
yeah send me a self-addressed and you
might get a lamp a lamp
this is basically a garage sale for
barry
you might be and it may or may not work
whose football trophy is that i know
it's not yours
there's trophies
okay
hang on
oh wait remember when i said that about
dust i uh i lied
if you're watching this on video look at
that look at that dusty look at that
there you go yeah by the way there's no
returns on anything no no no no no
returns it's yours to keep
player of the week 2006. i guarantee you
i'm the first one to pick this up since
2006. since i'd put it in that spot did
you put it right here yeah there's my
signed
autographed photos of oprah and reggie
white oprah really oprah you could win a
signed autographed photo yeah from oprah
yeah this seems like a really great
contest guys
so excited you have no idea
when something from barry's basement so
how do we how do we enter this
incredible contest that's going to
change lives forever
all i need is an address
send us an email with your address yeah
i can't send the lan you're gonna have
to pay for the lamp shipping because
that's expensive okay and along the way
you'll probably get a sticker and a
koozie too yes because yeah still got
some of those yeah we've got plenty of
t-shirts and you want do you want to set
up like a
a patreon so that you can at least get
uh shipping costs covered
you know i don't know if you saw last
week's episode where we had david grimes
on but you know what i'm gonna let you
guess the answer to that i i i bragged
on taco and our website our website
looks amazing
great job and i bring that up because
there's a merch
link if you want a t-shirt or a koozie
or i've got a few stickers how about
this you buy something from the merch uh
site and barry throws in something from
this house along with it you get a
personal item along with your uh yeah it
could be it could be a um
cd of
the ozark mountain daredevils
uh the car over the lake album oh nice
you know i'm really getting into cds
like i am getting to see this lately
yeah
you might expect to pay
upwards of a hundred dollars oh my god
you could do one order now what was that
thing that we did as a kid not you uh
but what was that thing that we did as a
kid where we uh
you signed up you got 30 cds for 20
seconds oh like the columbia house yeah
that's where a lot of these came from
2022 columbia house is corridor's house
so yeah
make first eight or are free
first eight
and then you're committed
[Laughter]
what if that is it we we create a thing
where you get a shipment from barry's
house every month you know what a month
i love it you get a new cd or or
something from his house every month you
know what else we have still our uh
mixtapes
we do have some mixtures lot of mixed
jobs left huh six tapes and i can record
more if there's demand
yeah so buy sign up and buy a shirt yeah
um you'll be amazed at what you get yeah
you know what you could you could be
going home with terry bradshaw's book
it's only a game it's a good book
that's a good book
can't get rid of that
maybe that's off limits all right so
there you go that's our next contest
sign up today thewhatpodcast.com
anything else we need to get to today
guys
fact that i can think of well i'm just
happy to see you yeah just glad to have
you here all right wish la uh wish you
luck in new york
boy we'll see moving moving to the big
city this is like babe two in you know
move
because again it goes to the big city he
goes to new york
or home alone too of all the you know
every sequel is like oh it's like they
take the character and go to the big
city home alone 2 is lost in new york
babe 2 is in the big city of all the
movies that are set in new york your
face when he said that or taco chose
baby
is it because is was it a baby or a babe
no a babe was a pig
yeah well look who's talking to said in
new york see some babies this is this is
a thing every sequel is like a moves to
the big city type
um babe too you probably got a copy over
here somewhere
we'll pull it out and watch it i bet i
do over there
i bet i do there's no telling much babe
uh so
you know what you might get sit by we're
gonna livestream watching babe too you
might get some uh vcr tapes recorded by
kelly's dad just a view of the family
matlock episode cool matlock episode wow
you got neat you got any rockford files
manics you know we've been watching man
it's just terrible it's not as good as i
remember
it
never is never is it never holds up but
you know it does hold up when you
re-watch it
all right that's what podcasts we'll uh
talk to you about random [ __ ] next week
[Music]
consequence podcast network